president biden's meeting with russian
president putin tomorrow
will mark a new chapter in the
complicated history between the u.s
and russia for generations u.s leaders
have turned to direct diplomacy
with their russian and soviet
counterparts to try to bridge
deep divisions often with mixed success
ed o'keefe is traveling with president
biden ed good morning
good morning even at the peak of the
cold war when nuclear-armed conflicts
seem imminent
u.s and russian leaders met often for
frank discussions
long time observers agreed that the
relationship's now at a low point
but at least the leaders are still
talking the conference is to seal
hitler's fate and establish lasting
peace
near the end of the second world war
leaders from the globe's major allied
powers met in yalta to negotiate peace
this meeting crystallizes the allied
resolve the agreement set up a
decades-long cold war pitting u.s
democracy against soviet communism
still diplomacy continued for 15 minutes
the two men hurled charges and counter
charges at one another
in 1959 then vice president richard
nixon traveled to russia and held an
impromptu debate with soviet leader
nikita khrushchev
there must be a free exchange of ideas
khrushchev later became the first soviet
leader to set foot on u.s soil
u.s quarantine cuba but that cultural
exchange didn't head off the hottest
confrontation of the decades-long
standoff between nuclear
powers this government as promised
has maintained the closest surveillance
of the soviet military buildup
on the island of cuba we came within a
hair's breath i mean literally seconds
of nuclear war matthew rajansky studies
russia at the wilson center
staring down into that abyss i think it
was initially the kennedy administration
but then subsequent administrations
really did value arms control the
picture you see is president reagan and
mikhail gorbachev
breaking up against all odds president
ronald reagan and soviet leader mikhail
gorbachev
built a relationship that nearly
eliminated nuclear weapons
and ultimately eased tensions mr
gorbachev
down this wall continued engagement
helped bring down the berlin wall
ultimately leading to the collapse of
the soviet union
president clinton tried to cozy up to
new russian president boris yeltsin
hoping to bring about western style
reforms as yeltsin has struggled to hold
power in the kremlin the russian's
message to the u.s has been blunt
instead the agent yeltsin was replaced
by a young former soviet intelligence
agent
named vladimir putin after putin's first
year in office president george w
bush believed they could find common
ground we had a very good dialogue
i was able to
get a sense of his soul but gained
little traction
president barack obama attempted a
russian reset but his diplomatic wish
list went largely unfulfilled
and putin likes me putin says trump is
brilliant i love that one he says i'm
brilliant
president donald trump openly quartered
the russian leader fueling suspicions of
collusion that plagued his presidency
and despite u.s intelligence reports
that russia tried to influence the
presidential election on his behalf
trump met with putin in 2018 and
appeared to accept
his denial i have president putin
he just said it's not russia i will say
this i don't see any reason why it would
be
president biden has met with putin
before but more recently he's called the
russian leader a threat to democracy
and even a killer putin's response
it takes one to no one it's not the
early cold war we're not going to go to
war with each other tomorrow
and yet there is this existential
element to the tension today where putin
thinks we're coming after him
and quite frankly our democracy has been
threatened by putin's behavior
this week's meeting follows another
election where u.s officials say russia
tried to interfere
and that the russian government is at
least tacitly permitting crippling cyber
attacks on u.s businesses carried out by
russian hackers
white house officials say that among
many topics of discussion for
wednesday's meeting
is trying to sort out rules of the road
for future cyber attacks
ed o'keefe for us ed thank you and of
course when they get they gather for
that meeting all of that history that ed
just went through is going to be in the
room with them
in the room with us a gentleman we saw
in that report a very young anthony
recognized that fella who was that guy
in moscow i have no idea you have an
agent i still have the tie that's the
only thing i can again
i'm pretty sure that ties down on harry
potter that color scheme at least
that's right i really had to get
creative remember in 2009
that's right secretary of state clinton
presented the button to reset the
relationship
with russia to the russian foreign
minister turned out it was just a button
toy yeah it didn't actually work
resetting this time is going to be very
difficult
all right ed o'keefe thank you again